hey guys mkbhd here back with just a
quick update video letting you guys know
a couple things and requesting a comment
of some sort uh this is an update video
to let you guys know i'll actually be
doing a series of youtube video tips
i've been getting a lot of questions
recently since i got the t2i and since
i've
been editing with camtasia studio 7
about the types of videos that i do and
questions about how to produce some
things like voice overs lighting uh
camera angles etc so if you leave a
comment below just asking you know a
simple question something you want to
see in the series of videos uh maybe in
addition to that list or a
suggestion i will be happy to do a video
in honor of your comments so
that's just a quick video i want to let
you guys know and possibly get some
suggestions from you
on here or on twitter at mkbhd also keep
in mind the 12 giveaways of christmas
are still going on my giveaway actually
ends on the 20th so be sure to get your
comments in by then
pretty exciting with the beats by dre
studios up for grabs until then this has
been mkbhd just with a quick video
asking again if you have a comment uh
for a series of videos on youtube tips
i'd be happy to work on
screencasts hardware reviews things like
that anything you want so i'll leave
your suggestions and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching peace
you